dear kitna I've noticed that you're
spending quite a bit of time with
Bernard and I think it's time that I
told you the rules of friendship rule
number one be picky I know you don't
care as much for Snoop frog and I saw
you actually pee on Larry so I'm
assuming the two of you aren't that
tight but that's okay a friend to all is
a friend to none
Aristotle said that use those little
Pekinese that live next door I think
he's dead now smart dog
although I did see him eat a sock once
rule number two
friends are there in times of need
because of some strange malady
or curse our human friend is rendered
completely unconscious each night and as
friends we must do everything we can
that's right kitten classic CPR one lick
on the nose for every three breaths and
then what are you doing that's hair what
are you trying to you're trying to
resuscitate hair if those don't work
try warming the gigantic head just
remember kitten every morning when she
wakes up it's because we saved her life
rule number three you have to set the
limits you know I like a belly rub as
much as the next guy but when it's over
it's over if they don't get the hint
from krazee-eyez then you get out of
there and you present them the butt a
reminder that they have to be friends
with all of you not just the soft parts
and that kitten is why we sit with our
bums pointed to the things we love
there's an old cat saying that goes
until you've puked on the floor and
they've stepped in it you don't know the
depth of your friendship it's a very
literal metaphor isn't it rule number
four be assertive if you need something
out of the friendship you take it the
human doesn't get this at all by the way
I mean there's times when she calls me
and I'm like seriously I'm five feet
away you know if you want it come & get
it
rule number five talking is overrated
the mouth hole is where the food goes
and nothing shows that the human loves
us more than her offerings of moist
delicious wet food it says so much more
than she could ever say deny reciprocate
brought them too nice for crickets and a
half-eaten spider
don't ask on story but trust me based on
how fast they grab those things off the
floor you think that they appreciate it
rule number six what is that a little
catnip what the heck it's 5 o'clock
somewhere
[Music]
once the empties purple Tinkerbell with
that tiny hammer when why is the three
of you Queen Elizabeth II my closest
friend
where's the bunny oh oh it's you sorry
about that
that must have passed out rule number
seven friendships do have a kind of
rhythm sometimes you might need some
alone time even a lot of a long time you
know become friends with you and
sometimes you and your friends might
drift apart
but even then with your best friends
when you need them you'll find each
other again and you won't have to say a
single word that's nice so is this a
good time to tell you that while I was
on catnip I may or may not have pooped
in one of your shoes and I am not sure
which one
[Music]
didn't go on doorbell good